alors claude allègre vous aimait
beaucoup les sigles vous aimez bien les
nappes mais bien tout ce qui est signe
que tout ce qui est technocratique
alors on va vous faire une interview
sigle
[Applaudissements]
est
ce que la démocratie
a plus à craindre
de letea ou de l'ena
on n'y a pas de photos le théâtre je
veux dire là le terrorisme non mais le
terrorisme est une chose qu'il faut
éradiquer il n'ya pas tia et ça se
compare pas très bien pour vous la
meilleure illustration du progrès c'est
le tgv ou liv et g
et c'est une c'est une très très bonne
question ben en fait c'est une très
bonne version allègre et est très
difficile je pense que je pense que
liv et j'essaie quand même c'est quand
même la libération des femmes c'est
quand même plus important ptg que le tgv
est ce que l'environnement est plus
menacé par les ogm ou par les hlm au nom
par les hlm les ogm sa menace personne
c'est complètement à ccc temps c'est un
fantasme ya aucun accident avec les ogm
les les ogm permettent quand vous pensez
que deschamps ont été saccagés alors
qu'on préparait des vaccins ouais non
pas bien sûr les hlm oui il faut il faut
décider de prendre un certain nombre de
banlieue et la gelée raser et de les
reconstruire de reconstruire et y penser
et c'est ce que je proposais avec le
budget 2011 au lieu de baisser les
impôts aurait dû faire ça
absolument ce que vous regardez en
priorité chez une fille
son cv
son rib ou son qi
leur hymne sûrement pas que je sais pas
je prends le cul le québécois que c'est
tout
dakar dakar alors les trois lettres qui
pourrait vous faire fuir devant une
fille
mst ou mlf
les deux à
hi hi hi la dernière votre vie sexuelle
oh là là naît oui non mais vous c'est
gentil de l'autre franchement y'a pas de
soucis votre vie sexuelle c'est plutôt
sas ras ou sos
ras
mesdames messieurs
robert laffont qui pour être sûr de ne
rien rater le in a l'habitude abonnez
vous je m'étais un peu ce bleu